- No, so do you still find
yourself carrying them
around everywhere?
Because here's the thing,
one of my kids I can,
but one of 'em I'm like,
look, you're too sturdy.
- No, the little one.
My wife and I are both from the Midwest
and we're like bigger people.
- Yeah.
- And that little one, man.
It's one thing where
I'm just picking her up
and then moving her here.
That's one thing.
We went to Yosemite.
- Oh no.
- We went hiking, and I
was like, oh, it's fine.
She can walk uphill.
And then you realize it's
like a three mile uphill walk.
There it is.
That's me in front of the--
- [Kelly] It's beautiful
though, I love Yosemite.
- I love it, it's amazing.
The majesty of the redwoods.
10 out 10 recommend.
Unless you have a thick baby.
(audience laughs)
If you have a thick baby
you're gonna end up
carrying that thing uphill
until your arms just start giving out
and then you pass it on to your wife.
Not it, her, I love you.
I love you.
- It feels like an it,
when it's that heavy.
- It just feels like a sack of potatoes.
- They go dead weight on you.
- They go dead weight.
And so you end up just trading her off
until three days later
you go to pick something
up and you can't move
because your body's so jacked
from carrying a thickie.
- Yes, I have a thickie, yes.
I understand this.
What I do is the piggyback ride.
- [Ike] Yes, that's good.
- That's easier for me cuz it's just
like a backpack with stones in it
but the problem is then
they start choking you.
- Yes!
- 'Cause they get lazy and they choke you
and I'm like, I need air.
- I know.
I'm always worried that I'm gonna have
the world's most embarrassing death
where I'm just slowly asphyxiated
by my child on my shoulders.
It's a real problem, people.
- They're amazing.
I'm like, I'm not a jungle gym.
- No, we have one at Mindy's house.
We'll go there.
We don't have one at our
house, but Mindy house.
- We have a Capri Sun.
- Yes.
- Well there are a bunch of
talented people in this movie.
So who would you still like to work with?
- I've been so lucky to work with such
great comedic actors and
drama actors and performers.
I'm kind of looking for the next thing.
And I kind of am looking to
do a collab with Ina Garten.
The Barefoot Contessa.
- The Barefoot Contessa.
- That's her right there.
- [Kelly] I was like, who?
And then I just got it.
- I'm obsessed with her.
- I love you.
- I watch her videos
and she makes chicken for
her sweet husband, Jeffrey.
And I'm like, this is what I want.
I want to be working with this person.
- This is on your vision board.
- Only her, my vision board
is just one big picture of
the Barefoot Contessa.
Obviously we could cook things together,
but we could solve mysteries together.
We could do a sitcom together.
I just want to be in the
barefoot contessa business.
- I like that.
Solving crime while cooking.
- While cooking.
A cooking mystery show!
How good is that?
Thank you.
- Doesn't everyone wanna dive in this hit?
- The show's called Dive In.
- Dive in.
- Because it could work on both levels.
- So we were talking about high school.
So in high school did you
ever get caught doing anything
that you shouldn't?
I feel like you were maybe a prankster.
- I was a bit of a prankster.
- Okay, that's not shocking.
- I remember for our prom
one year I was like, guys
I figured out a full proof plan.
I'm gonna get the alcohol.
- Oh my God.
- So I placed this big
order at a liquor store
and I just used my grandfather's name.
'Cause he passed away.
He wasn't gonna use it.
- So he wasn't coming to get any liquor.
- He was not gonna come to claim.
He passed away 10 years before that.
And so I went there
and I found someone to
go in and buy it for us.
And then a month later my dad was like,
hey, I ran into my friend,
Fred who owns the liquor store.
And he said, my dad came in
and ordered a bunch of Zima
which is funny because my dad
didn't like Zima and he died in 1986.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- I got in a little bit
of trouble for that one.
- You live in too small of a town.
- Chicago?
- Or your family frequents
the liquor store.
(laughs)
- A fog is lifting.
- I was like, wait.
- My dad's like I was at
the liquor store again
this morning.
- I was saying hi to
everyone I know there.
- I was just in the parking lot
having a drink out of a bag.
- But even if you're from Chicago,
you all have your little neighborhoods.
- Chicago is very provincial.
People do know each other in Chicago.
It's a huge city, but it is weird.
So you were right.
- Wasn't a weird thing to say, Ike.
(laughs)
It's like a metropolis.